[Applause]
looney will track it down
steph one more time for the advantage
good
if at first you don't succeed you know
what they say
try try again especially if your name is
stephen curry
what a big shot so looney gave steph a
second opportunity
and he cashes in at three in a one point
lead
with 13 seconds left he's just so big
time
and he never loses confidence and you
missed the first one
this movement without the ball that
little juke move without the ball
got him the advantage against o'neill
and again
using gobert who is guarding draymond
nobody
it should have been gobert but you got
so much space
look where governor is he's the only one
that's supposed to be guarding this
screen
now kavon looney has double-digit
rebounds in three straight games he had
never done that in his career
he has the big offensive rebound 13
boards tonight
and he gives steph the extra opportunity
now
is it bogdanovic or is it clarkson
for the win for utah they're going to be
look